quand j'étais enfant, mon père me disait
beaucoup de choses chérie, la
vie est une question d'échange, il
disait tout le temps qu'il disait que
quand je volais des jouets à l'école,
il disait que quand il me conduisait
au pensionnat, il  disais que
même quand je sortais très tard et
qu'il voulait que je rentre tôt et je
trouvais ça extrêmement ennuyeux et
j'écoutais tranquillement la figure de mon père
quand j'ai eu 22 ans
mon père est mort donc c'était logique pour moi de
commencer à  chercher le sens de ses
mots échangés la vie c'est l'
échange donc naturellement je suis allé travailler
aux Nations Unies et là j'ai
appris tellement de choses j'ai appris
à rédiger une présentation PowerPoint et j'ai
appris à organiser des réunions comment
sourire de manière très diplomatique mais je
n'ai jamais vraiment appris ce que c'était
donner ou recevoir alors je suis revenu en France
pourquoi plus tard et j'ai commencé un mouvement avec
deux autres amis qui étaient aussi très
frustrés par le travail dans les
organisations internationales  ions un mouvement appelé Singha
cela signifie connexion en lingala une
langue parlée au Congo ce mouvement ce
mouvement a été conçu afin de faire correspondre les
personnes qui étaient des nouveaux arrivants avec des personnes
qui étaient des locaux l'idée derrière cela est
de créer un capital social autour de nos
différences pour connecter les gens et
grâce à cet échange stimulant, mais
lorsque vous mettez des personnes qui ne se connaissent pas
qui n'ont pas la même
langue qui n'ont pas la même
culture ne viennent pas du même
pays, vous les mettez dans la même pièce
et vous pouvez  se retrouver avec des histoires amusantes, nous
étions confrontés à de nombreux défis,
y compris des défis interculturels, par
exemple mon amie Keith Lee un jour,
elle organisait un dîner avec des amis afghans
et elle a passé toute la journée à préparer
la nourriture
.  elle voulait faire un gâteau
tu sais ce genre de gâteau que tu fais
pendant les Horreurs ce genre de gâteau qui
sent vraiment très bon avec beaucoup de
chocolat et de vanille  et quelques étincelles
dessus tu commences à avoir faim tu sais
ouais
alors quand l'heure du dessert est venue, elle a sorti
le gâteau du réfrigérateur et elle l'a mis
sur la table devant ses amis et
elle a dit qui en voulait,
elle était vraiment enthousiaste à propos du
gâteau et les amis, ils étaient comme non
merci,
donc si vous vouliez juste être poli,
elle était vraiment frustrée par cela, alors elle
a ramené le gâteau à la cuisine,
puis elle est revenue et a terminé le dîner
et quelque temps plus tard, elle a appris que
ce qui s'est passé ce soir-là s'appelait
tahaafe la moitié signifie être poli en
personne donc la moitié cohérente
refusant systématiquement quelque chose qu'on
vous propose donc en suivant pour avoir
quelque chose que ce gamin aurait fait ce
serait comme voulez-vous du gâteau non
merci  s'il vous plaît j'insiste non
merci voulez-vous du gâteau non merci et
à la fin je dirais oui s'il vous plaît
le truc c'est qu'il voulait aussi être
poli donc tous voulaient être
polis mais pas de la même façon  y et aujourd'hui
ils rient encore de l'histoire
et de l'histoire de Keith il m'a été raconté à
tous les gens de Singha pour les
aider et les soutenir dans
des histoires d'interaction interculturelles comme
celle-ci j'en ai vu des milliers surtout
depuis 2015 nous avons lancé  une plateforme de co-hébergement
qui a été conçue pour permettre aux
locaux d'héberger des nouveaux arrivants pendant un certain temps et
le résultat a été énorme en deux mois
nous avons eu 12 000 personnes locales
postulant pour accueillir des nouveaux arrivants et
néanmoins nous avons eu une si grande
mobilisation citoyenne mais après six mois  un
nouveau venu moyen a pu trouver un
emploi qui correspondrait à ce travail qui
correspondait à ses compétences une
maison durable mais plus que tout, ils avaient des
amis et c'est quelque chose que les
habitants
devaient faire parce que si au début les
habitants étaient comme je vais aider  quelqu'un
en hébergeant cette personne à la fin il
était très content de l'expérience
car ils avaient des amis et ils avaient
déconstruit leurs stéréotypes sur la
migration  on a eu plein de bonnes histoires
et il y en a une autre que j'ai envie de
vous raconter c'est une histoire de Mohammed et Boone
ou Mohammed vient d'Afghanistan
il a 22 ans c'est un fanatique de
hip-hop
il adore les sciences politiques et il adore
TED Talks aussi donc un jour il veut en faire
un qui se dit et il a rencontré
Benoit qui est un célèbre cinéaste et
auteur vivant à New York mais venant
souvent en France et quand j'ai décidé d'
écrire un livre sur l'histoire de Muhammad mais au
bout d'un moment  après avoir commencé à
parler de politique Trump au Moyen-
Orient, ils ont réalisé qu'ils avaient des choses
en commun, alors il a commencé à
boire du vin avec des amis et à essayer
du fromage français ou à traîner à la
campagne et c'était plus qu'une histoire
d'écrire une biographie  de quelqu'un c'était
une histoire de connexion et à la fin
Mohamed mes mémoires Mohamed ma mère et
moi sommes sortis dans les bibliothèques donc je
voudrais citer les dernières phrases du
livre pour vous donner une idée de leur
relationhi  p
Mohamed a décidé de me raconter son histoire une
histoire qu'il n'a jamais racontée à personne une
histoire qui sera connue désormais une
histoire qui fait écho à ma propre quête de l'Ouest une
histoire qui m'a permis de
mieux comprendre le mot en mettant de la distance
avec ma propre culture  et comment nous pouvons
réinventer comment nous sommes une histoire qui nous a fait des
amis
vous remarquerez peut-être à ce stade que je
n'ai pas utilisé le mot réfugié migrant
demandeur d'asile expat parce que je suis
convaincu que ce sont des étiquettes et les
étiquettes ne définissent pas notre identité mais
quoi  définit notre identité c'est nos
émotions c'est nos rencontres et
nos cultures nos communautés donc je pense que nous avons tous
besoin de sortir de notre zone de confort pour
expérimenter le sens de l'échange
allons parler avec des gens qu'on ne connaît pas
mangeons du gâteau que l'étranger voudrait  proposez-
nous d'aller dans notre quartier et de
visiter des centres communautaires
faisons avec et pas pour les autres Je suis
convaincu aussi qu'au début, ce que nous
pensons être différent avec les autres est en
fait ce qui peut nous rapprocher d'eux  il y a un
an, j'ai passé quelques temps avec John
Bettis de Fuko, il est l'un des fondateurs
de l'Union européenne et nous
parlions de la signification de la
fraternité la fraternité est l'un des
trois mots de la devise française Liberté
égalité une fraternité et il a dit
quelque chose qui  m'a vraiment ouvert les yeux
il a dit que la fraternité est basée sur le
fait que tu donnes tu reçois et ensuite
tu rends je pense que c'est l'
algorithme secret de l'interaction sociale et cet
algorithme secret de l'interaction sociale
peut permettre à chacun d'avoir un
impact concret sur la société donc  aujourd'hui je pense que mon
père avait à la fois raison et tort il
m'a dit comment donner il m'a dit comment recevoir
mais pas vraiment comment rendre et je
pense que toi si tu ne fais que donner ou
recevoir tu manques le but de
ce que tu  peut construire alors
donnons recevons et rendons merci